There's a reason to speak out because
it's the only it's the because it's the
only religion that acts like the mafia
that will fuck kill you if you say the
wrong thing, draw the wrong picture, or
write the wrong book. You did.
In that memorable video clip from 2014,
Bill Maher was referring to Islam's
blasphemy laws, which ban often on pain
of death, any insult to Islam, and
especially its prophet, Muhammad. Little
did Mah know, but the similarities
between Islam and the mafia far exceed
punishing those who say, draw, or write
the wrong thing. And in this video, we
will look at 10 such similarities.
Number one, Allah and Muhammad as
godfather and under boss. The pedrino of
a larger mafia organization or family,
literally the godfather or boss of
bosses, has absolute control over over
his subordinates and is often greatly
feared by the rest of the family for his
ruthlessness. But he typically has an
underboss, a right-hand man who issues
his orders and enforces his will. The
Godfather himself is often inaccessible
and rarely seen.
Mafia members need to go through the
underboss or other highranking
associates.
Now compare this with the relationship
between Allah and his messenger
Muhammad. In Arabic, by the way,
Muhammad is most commonly referred to as
al- Rasul, the messenger, not al- Nebi,
the prophet. Unlike the Christian God, a
personal God, a father that according to
Christ is to be communed with directly.
See Matthew 6:9. Islam's God, Allah, is
unreachable, unknowable, untouchable.
Like the Godfather, he is inaccessible.
His orders are revealed by his
messenger, Muhammad. If God calls on the
faithful to come now, let us reason
together. See Isaiah 11:18. Allah says,
"Do not ask questions about things that
if made known to you would only cause
you pain." Quran 5101. Just follow
orders.
Two, a piece of the action. The
Godfather and his underboss always get a
piece of the action, a cut of all spoils
acquired by their subordinates. So do
Allah and his messenger Muhammad. Quran
8:41 informs Muslims that quote, "15 of
all war booty you acquire goes to Allah
and the messenger."
Why does he always get the prettiest
one? Three assassinations. The Godfather
through his under boss regularly sends
mafia men to make hits to assassinate
those he deems enemies.
So did Allah and his messenger. One
example, a Jewish poet Ashra once
insulted Muhammad people of the well,
prompting the latter to exclaim, who is
willing to kill Kabin al- Ashraf who has
hurt Allah and his apostle. Oh Razalah,
would you like me to kill him? Yes. In
order to kill Cabb, I have to lie. Is it
okay to lie to please Allah? Say what
you like. You are absolved in that
matter.
Muslimma traveled to Kab and began to
denigrate Islam and Muhammad until his
disaection became so convincing that the
poet took him into his confidence. Soon
thereafter, however, Muslma appeared
with another crypto Muslim. And while
Kab's guard was down, they slaughtered
the Jewish poet,
bringing his head to Muhammad to the
usual triumphant cries of Allah Akbar.
Four, circumstance is everything. While
the mafia adheres to a general code of
conduct, as with all human institutions,
its leader, the Godfather, issues more
fluid orders according to shifting
circumstances. This is very reminiscent
of the entire revelation of the Quran
where later verses or commands
contradict earlier verses and commands
depending on circumstances. In Islamic
Jewish prudence, this is known as an
Mansuk or the doctrine of abrogation.
The Quran itself talks about this in the
following verses.
Quran surah al bakar verse 106. Allah
does not abrogate any verse but
substitutes something similar or better.
Quran surah ar 39. Allah eliminates and
confirms what he wills. Quran surah anah
verse 101. Allah substitutes one
revelation with another and he knows
best. When Muslims are weak, Allah told
the prophet these verses. Quran surah
albakar verse 256. There is no
compulsion in religion. Quran surah al-
muzil verse 10 11. Be patient and bear
with those who deny the truth. Quran
surah verse 16-17.
Be patient with the evildoers. Quran
surah taha verse 130. Show patience to
the pagans. Quran surah Mariam vers
8384.
Don't be in a haste to fight the
disbelievers.
But once the messenger grew strong
enough, Allah issued new revelations
calling for allout war or jihad, till
Islam became supreme. Quran surah
alanfal 39. Fight them until all
religion is for Allah. Quran surah atba
verse 5. Fight and slay the pagans
wherever you find them. Quran surah atba
verse 29. Fight the Christians and the
Jews until they pay Jiza willingly,
fully humbled. Quran surah Ali Imran
vers 85. Any religion other than Islam
is not acceptable. Quran surah al 33.
Execute, crucify, torture those who
opposes Muhammad.
While other religions and scriptures may
have contradictions, only Islam
rationalizes them through abrogation.
That is by giving prominence to later
verses which are seen as the latest
decision of the deity, the latest
decision of the godfather.
Five, clan loyalty. Loyalty is of
paramount importance to the mafia.
Following elaborate rituals of blood
oaths, mafia members are expected to
maintain absolute loyalty to the family
on pain of death. Mafia members are
expected to always be available for the
family, even if your wife is about to
give birth, as one of the mafia's ten
commandments puts it, and to defend the
godfather and his honor, even if it
costs their lives.
[Music]
Now, compare this to the widespread
violence and upheavalss that occur
whenever Allah or his prophet is
offended. whenever non-Muslim infidels
blaspheme the Muslim godfather and his
underboss or in the words of Bill Maher.
It's the because it's the only religion
that acts like the mafia that will kill
you if you say the wrong thing, draw the
wrong picture or write the wrong book.
Islam's loyalty and enmity doctrine
which calls on Muslims to be loyal to
one another even if they dislike each
other is especially illustrated. Quran
971 declares that quote the believing
Muslim men and believing Muslim women
are allies of one another. See also 872
to 875. And according to Muhammad,
quote, "A Muslim is the brother of a
Muslim. All things of a Muslim are
inviable for his brother in faith, his
blood, his wealth, and his honor."
Precisely those three things that mafia
members respect among each other.
This is why Muslims in the US armed
forces habitually lash out when being
deployed to fight in Muslim nations such
as US Army Major Nadal Hassan. Remember
him? In 2009, he killed 13 American
soldiers rather than deployed to and
fight Muslims in Afghanistan. A scenario
which he described as his worst
nightmare. There have been other
American military men to engage in such
behavior since.
Six, death to traitors. Once a fledging
mafia member takes the oath of loyalty
to the mafia, including the omea code of
silence and secrecy, trying to leave the
family is seen as a betrayal punishable
by death. Any family member, great or
small, is given authority to kill the
traitor, the turn code.
I'll compare this to Islam. To be born
to a Muslim father immediately makes the
newborn a Muslim. There are no oaths to
be taken, much less any choice in the
matter. And according to Islamic law, if
born Muslims at any point in their lives
choose to leave Islam, they are deemed
apostates, traitors, and punished,
including by death. Any zealous Muslim,
not just the authorities, is justified
in killing the apostate. Hence why
Muslim families that kill apostate
children are rarely ever prosecuted in
the Muslim world. In the words of
Muhammad, the messenger or under boss of
Allah, the Godfather, quote, "Whoever
leaves his Islamic faith, kill him.
[Applause]
Number seven, distrust and dislike of
outsiders. Aside from loyalty to the
family, mafia members are strongly
discouraged from befriending or freely
associating with outsiders who by nature
are not to be trusted as they are not
part of the family except in those
situations when such outside friendships
help advance the family's position.
Similarly, the second half of the
aforementioned Islamic doctrine of
loyalty and enmity. The enmity part al
calls on Muslims to maintain distance
from and bear enmity for all non-Muslim
infidels. Thus, Quran 551 warns Muslims
against quote taking the Jews and
Christians as friends and allies.
Whoever among you takes them for friends
and allies, he is surely one of them.
According to the mainstream Islamic
exesis of Alabari Quran 551 means that
the Muslim who quote allies with them
non-Muslims and enables them against the
believers that same one is a member of
their faith and community that is he is
a defector an apostate in a word an
enemy there are many more such verses
Quran 4144 declares oh you who believe
do not take the infidels as allies
instead of the believers do you wish to
give Allah the godfather a clear case
against elves.
Eight, deception and dissimulation. As
mentioned, close relations to non-mafia
individuals that prove advantageous to
the family. For example, collaboration
with a crooked cop are permissible as
long as a mafia keeps a safe distance,
keeps the outsider at arms length.
Now, compare this to Quran 3:28. It
says, quote, "Believers, do not take
infidels for friends and allies instead
of believers unless you but guard
yourselves against them, taking
precautions." According to the standard
Quran commentary of Alabari, taking
precautions means, quote, "If you
Muslims are under their non-Muslims
authority, fearing for yourselves,
behave loyally to them with your tongue
while harboring inner animosity for
them. But know that Allah has forbidden
believers from being friendly or on
intimate terms with the infidels rather
than with believers except when infidels
are above them in authority. Should that
be the case, let them act friendly
towards them while preserving their
religion.
After interpreting Quran 328 as meaning
that Muslims may protect themselves
through outward show when under
non-Muslim authority,
one of Islam's most celebrated exedites,
quotes Muhammad's close companion saying
as recorded in Sah Bkari, a canonical
hadith, quote, truly we smile to the
faces of some people while our hearts
curse them.
This sort of reminds me of this one
scene from, I believe, the movie Casino,
where a mob member makes and spits in a
sandwich for some cop that he has some
shady business with.
The idea of hating outsiders is
apparently so ingrained in Islam that
one leading Salafi cleric in Egypt, Dr.
Yeser alhami insists that while Muslim
men may marry Christian and Jewish
women, they must hate them in their
heart and show them that they hate them
in the hopes that they convert to the
family of Islam. I actually translated
his word some 11 years ago.
have anchorage.
foreign.
for
saidchech. Number
nine, I'm going to make him an offer he
can't refuse. Although the novel turned
movie The Godfather is fictitious, it
definitely captures much of the mafia's
modus operendi. Consider, for example,
that most famous of lines. The Godfather
says this to one of his godsons, an
aspiring actor and singer. After being
turned down by a studio director for a
role that he desperately wanted, the
godson had turned to his godfather for
aid. And that's what he said. I'm going
to make him an offer he can't refuse. As
the movie progresses, it becomes clear
that the offer that can't be refused
consists of nothing less than violence
and death threats. After the director
rejects the Godfather's offer, he
awakens the next morning to find the
bloodied and decapitated head of his
favorite stallion in bed with him. The
Godson subsequently gets the movie role.
Throughout the context of the entire
Godfather trilogy, which captures well
the mafia's approach to business, making
someone an offer they can't refuse means
do as I say or suffer the consequences,
possibly death. Now, compare this to
Islam's three-fold choice. On Muhammad's
orders, whenever Muslims conquer a
territory in the name of Islam, its
non-Muslim inhabitants are given three
choices. One, convert to Islam, join the
family. Two, keep your religious
identity but pay tribute Jiza to be
discussed and live as an outsider. Or
three, war to the death. Throughout
history, converting to Islam has been an
offer that countless non-Muslims could
not refuse. In fact, this offer is
responsible for transforming much of the
Middle East and North Africa, which was
Christian majority in the seventh
century when the jihad burst forth from
Arabia into what is today called the
Muslim world. And this offer is still
alive and well today. For example,
several older and disabled Christians
who were not able to join the Exodus out
of Islamic State controlled territories
way back then opted to convert to Islam
rather than die.
Like the mafia, then Islam's offer to
conquer non-Muslims, outsiders, is
basically, "Join our family. Help us and
we will help you. Refuse us and we will
hurt you."
10. The protection racket. Once the
mafia takes over a territory, one of the
primary ways it profits is by collecting
protection money from its inhabitants.
While the protection racket has several
aspects, one in particular is very akin
to an Islamic practice. Coercing people
in the mafia's territory to pay money
for protection, ostensibly against
outside elements. In fact, the
protection bought is usually from the
mafia itself. That is extortion money or
pidzo. Potential clients who refuse to
pay for the mafia's protection often
have their property vandalized and are
routinely threatened and harassed. Now
compare the collection of pidzo with the
Islamic concept of jiza. The word jiza
appears in Quran 9:29. Fight those among
the people of the book, Christians and
Jews, who do not believe in Allah nor
the last day nor forbid what Allah and
his messenger have forbidden nor embrace
the religion of truth until they pay the
jiza with willing submission and feel
themselves subdued. Similarly, in the
hadith, the messenger of Allah,
Muhammad, in our analogy, the underboss
regularly calls on Muslims to demand
Jiza from non-Muslims.
If they refuse to accept Islam, said the
prophet, demand from them the Jiza. If
they agree to pay, accept it from them
and hold off your hands. If they refuse
to pay Jiza, seek Allah's help and fight
them. Topping it all off, just as the
mafia rationalizes its collection of
protection money by portraying it as
money that buys mafia protection against
outsiders, when in fact the money
tribute mostly serves to protect the
clients from the mafia itself. So too do
Islam's apologists portray the
collection of Jiza as money meant to buy
Muslim protection against outsiders when
in fact the money Jiza buys protection
from Muslims themselves.
So there you have it, 10 similarities
between Islam and the mafia. But what
makes them so similar in the first
place? One clue is found in the fact
that the very word mafia, which means
hostility to the law, boldness, is
actually derived from an Arabic word
maka, which in translation means
bragging, boasting, bravado, swaggering.
This etmology is a reminder that Sicily,
birthplace of the mafia, was under Arab
Islamic domination for over 200 years.
Aside from a borrowed etmology, could
some of the mafia's modus operendi also
have been borrowed from Islam, isolated
on their island, could native Sicilians
have co-opted the techniques of social
control and exploitation that they had
lived under and learned from their
former overlords, albeit without the
Islamic veneer. Incidentally, the mafia
is hardly the only historical example of
a non-Muslim criminal organization to be
influenced by Islam.
For example, the thuggies, whence we get
the word thug, were a brotherhood of
allied bands and assassins who way and
savagely murdered travelers in India,
often by first feigning friendship.
Although they were associated with the
Hindu cult of Kali, as late as the 19th
century, a large number of thuggies
captured and convicted by the British
were Muslim.
The thuggish similarities are clear.
Along with assassinating his opponents,
including as seen through treachery,
Muhammad also personally engaged in
banditry, ransacking the caravans of
enemy tribes.
And if the words mafia and thug have
Arab Islamic an etmologies or
associations, the words assassinate and
assassin are of course derived straight
from a medieval Islamic sect, the
hasheen, who pioneered the use of
political assassination with promises of
a decidedly Islamic, that is hedonistic
paradise for the assassin who almost
certainly died. So there you have it.
Now you know that when people claim that
Islam is the only religion that acts
like the mafia that will effing kill you
if you say the wrong thing, drawing the
wrong picture or write the wrong book,
they are barely touching on the
similarities between the mafia and other
criminal organizations on the one hand
and Islam on the other. Bye.